el 24 de noviembre de 2021 27 migrantes
perdieron la vida en su intento por
llegar a Reino Unido pero qué pasó esa
noche cinco militares Fueron acusados
por inasistencia a personas en peligro
se trata de tres mujeres y dos hombres
que en el momento de los hechos
trabajaban en este centro de vigilancia
y rescate ubicado en El Paso de calé en
Francia ellos son sospechosos de no
haber enviado un equipo de rescate a
pesar de los múltiples llamados de
auxilio de los migrantes conversaciones
que radio France pudo obtener y lo
demostrarían
le envié nuestra ubicación por Whatsapp
la tiene No no he recibido nada aún y
ahora ya la recibió Ah sí la recibí
bueno espere llamaré un bote de rescate
y sin embargo ningún barco fue enviado
en otra conversación mientras la línea
está pausada una operadora del centro de
rescate ironiza sobre la situación
pero no entiendes No serás rescatado
tengo los pies en el agua Pero yo no te
pedí que embarcaras los rescatistas no
fueron enviados al lugar sino hasta el
día siguiente por la llamada de un
pescador una negligencia Según el
abogado de varias familias de las
víctimas que hoy exigen respuestas
militares que eran conscientes del
riesgo tomaron malas decisiones la
justicia decidirá si estas decisiones
demuestran negligencia frivolidad e
imprudencia de instrucciones dadas lo
veremos
entre las víctimas se encuentran varios
kurdos iraquíes como esta familia que
habíamos conocido días antes de la
tragedia contactados por teléfono la
administración marítima de la Mancha no
quiso comentar sobre el caso pero
asegura que confía en los operadores del
centro de rescate del paso de Cali